in the South Korean city of Suwon
there's no shortage of community spirit
for the second day South Korea reported
more recoveries from the corona virus
than new infections the Health Authority
has urged people to stay vigilant to
fight against new clusters and there's
still work to do these volunteers are
packing relief kits for those still in
quarantine the people in isolation must
be going through a hard time the box
isn't much but I hope it gives them
strength and they can cheer up in
Australia panic has caused fights in
supermarket shopping aisles from Monday
all gatherings of more than 500 people
will be banned Australia's nearest
neighbor isn't taking any chances
every person entering New Zealand
including returning New Zealand citizens
and residents will be required to enter
self-isolation for 14 days everybody in
Indonesia 2 million litres of
disinfectant are to be distributed among
mosques there are fears about how many
undetected cases there are across the
archipelago and the World Health
Organization has asked Indonesia to
intensify its monitoring quarantine and
tracing efforts the government confirmed
its first coronavirus cases last week
and as the number steadily Rises efforts
to contain the virus are ramping up
Jakarta's governor has announced all
schools will be shut for at least two
weeks many popular attractions like
theme parks zoos and museums will also
be closed these restrictions could be
extended if the virus continues to
spread through one of the world's most
densely populated cities it's the new
reality for millions around the world
events canceled attractions closed there
are few things that can get between
Indian cricket fans and the game they
love but now a match between India and
South Africa will be played with no
spectators as the alarm intensifies in
other parts of the world life's slowly
returning to normal in parts of China
with authorities last week declaring the
peak of the epidemic over Wuhan has
reported only a handful of cases for the
past two days these recovered patients
are leaving hospital and a one step
closer to returning to their normal
lives it could be months before the rest
of the world can do the same
Jessica Washington al-jazeera Jakarta